MARK MIRCHANDANI: Drug
research and development
is more challenging than ever,
requiring massive amounts
of data and complex analysis.
Join us as we talk to Recursion
Pharmaceuticals about how
they're using machine learning
to speed up the drug discovery
process on this
episode of Stack Chat.
Scott, thanks so much
for joining us today.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about what Recursion
Pharmaceuticals does?
SCOTT NIELSEN: Yes.
Recursion is-- we're trying
to bring new drugs to market.
And in order to do that,
we have to find new drugs,
discover new drugs.
And we're trying to turn that
problem into a machine learning
problem.
What that means and
how we do that is,
we are creating a large data
set consisting primarily
of cell microscopy images.
And so that means we take a lot
of pictures of a lot of cells
in a lot of different states--
so healthy cells,
sick cells, sick cells
combined with drugs, healthy
cells combined with drugs.
And try to learn
more information
about how those images change
under different circumstances.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what
does the architecture
look like that does the eventual
machine learning on these?
SCOTT NIELSEN: Currently,
we're taking about 60 terabytes
of images a week.
And so at the
beginning, that can
take across seven
different microscopes
about five days at times
to take that many images.
And so we're constantly--
as soon as those images are
available, we're
uploading them into GCS,
and sending off events
that those images are
available for processing.
And then we have a couple of
different Kubernetes clusters
running on GKE.
All our software is
deployed in there,
and we have a number
of applications
that are reacting
to these events,
aggregating them at
different levels,
and then scheduling
processing in our kind of jobs
Kubernetes cluster to
do different computation
on the images or the results
of a previous processing,
until we boil those down
into more refined features
through this feature
extraction process.
And then those features are
used, and analysis is done.
Runs through-- depending
on the type of experiment,
it runs through
different analyses
where all these results,
all these metrics,
quality metrics on the images,
and a lot of different things
are stored in a combination
of Cloud SQL and BigQuery.
And then all that data is used
to make decisions and design
our next round of experiments.
And so that's kind
of the process
that we go through at
Recursion on a weekly basis.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it sounds
like you did a lot of data
processing directly in
Kubernetes with Kubernetes
jobs, rather than using
a traditional big data
solution like Hadoop or Spark.
What made you kind of choose
to write your own Kubernetes?
SCOTT NIELSEN: I think there
is a number of factors.
So the two primary factors that
pushed us in that direction
was that we have all
these images coming off
the microscopes constantly.
And so we have this kind of
streaming flow of images.
And in order to wait for
the right batches that
are the most important, it
can take sometimes hours.
But we want certain feedback
on a lot of those images
much more quickly.
And so we wanted a
streaming solution
so we could get faster feedback
on a lot of these quality
metrics and stop problems
and save ourselves
money from taking pictures
that aren't valuable.
The second part of that
was we had a number
of existing services
that weren't written
in languages or in ways
that integrate nicely
into some of those tools.
And so some of those were
Cloud Functions or Lambda jobs
and other things that we
wanted to be able to not
have to rewrite all of that
in order to just orchestrate
this pipeline.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
Well, thanks so much for
coming in and telling us
a little bit about how you
built this entire solution,
taking a real big
problem, big data problem,
and turning it
into real insights.
SCOTT NIELSEN: Yeah, thank you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Check
out this quick guide
to try running Kubernetes
jobs of your own.
Thanks for watching, and
make sure to subscribe
for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on Stack Chat.